little PFT p.m. from the bar and how we
Roseman the general manager of the
Philadelphia Eagles kind enough to join
us now from the home office this looks
like it was your location for the three
days of the draft I think you're just
gonna permanently work out of there
until you retire or die well I'm not
hoping to do I work every day this is
where I worked before the draft and I'm
fortunate that I have this kind of space
you know I got four kids and a dog and I
kind of close the door and I think it's
soundproof or either that or my brain is
we know here's what's amazing because I
know NFL people are creatures I have it
so now that there's a new habit even
though it's only a one-time thing are
there gonna be guys like you that want
to continue next year doing the draft
the same way it was this year well I
think that we're gonna learn that we
don't need to guard our desk you know
like it's okay to go home it's okay to
work from home you know your kids have
something if people in our front office
and we try to do this anyway but I know
that we do good job it and maybe some of
us as leaders have to make sure we're
setting the tone so it's like if my kids
it's it's the spring you know during the
draft time it's the spring my kids got a
basketball game they got a baseball game
I got a walk next door to idol our vice
president flare person and say hey I'm
going to the game and you should go to
you shouldn't we can work at home you
know we shouldn't we've shown we can do
this at home and hey we're not home for
dinner in the fall when it's football
season so let's everyone go go home for
dinner you go work after the kids go to
bed so we can do it and I think it's a
great message it's a great message to
all of us you know families got to come
first and that's a fascinating human
dynamic that cuts across all industries
Howie because I think in any office
setting there's a compulsion to be there
you want to be seen there because how
hard you're working is regarded as a
function of how long you're in the
office regardless of what you're doing
at home you have to be there to be
regarded as somebody who's working hard
because only the people who are there
can feel like they're in that little
five of the hard workers there's no
doubt about it and the reality of it is
like for a lot of us who have kids that
are school age will never get this time
back you know so it's almost like it
should be the reverse right you should
almost be like the hardest you're
working should be when your kids are
like you know out of college and you're
kind of alone you're empty nesters as
opposed to the opposite where like you
got to be in your groove
during those years are your kids are in
your groove bunny and you're trying to
raise them too it's kind of interesting
this is definitely what you want to talk
about Bobby I know we talked about
whatever that's one of reasons I like
talking to you because you always find
something to talk about completely
different than what I intended to talk
about which prevents me from ever asking
you the tough questions and I spent all
that time at the office working on would
see how hard I work and of course yeah
the other cool thing is this the other
cool thing is we were supposed to talk
later this afternoon and I asked you to
change the time which I appreciate you
did with me because the Blue Angels are
doing a flyover in Philly I'm gonna take
my kids outside and we're gonna watch
them and and the Blue Angels are a huge
part of my family because we have
someone suspect for what they do but
i'ma tell you great story that you and I
haven't discussed so we go to Orange
Beach Alabama for a couple weeks each
summer my wife's family has gone there
for our whole life and we got a place
there and actually two blocks from Ozzie
Newsome right there on the water it's
very cool you know I always get a chance
to pick the brain of all Fame GM and we
go fishing and and we're out I'm the
Gulf and I'm fighting tomorrow right and
I'm fighting a Marlin and the Blue
Angels are doing maneuvers in the Gulf
right over that and we're by ourselves
you can't see a boat you can't see
anything for as far as the eye can see
and I'm fighting this Marlin and you
know how special it is to freaking catch
Marlin right there and I'm fighting it
and and the Blue Angels are starting to
mess with us and they come down right
over the boat and on our boat captain
his name is Charlie Wright and he was in
Vietnam until he gets PTSD right God so
now he ducks like he sees like the
fighter planes coming over rocking and
rolling I'm trying to hang on to this
Marlin but lo and behold oh wait
not the Marlin where's the Marlin I
don't have the whole Marlin
oh that's the front end that's the
business end of the Marlin like a says
that's that's the business end yeah well
that's good land at the barn at the
Marlin and the Blue Angels didn't land
on the boat so mission accomplished
counts all right let me ask you this
scale of one to ten how surprised were
you by the reaction locally and
nationally to the use of a second round
pick on jaylen hurts well I'll tell you
what I feel like nationally it's it's
been what I expected you know um pretty
rational understood you know and and
I've been in Philly a long time we have
unbelievably passionate fans and I love
it you know I've been part of his
community and our fans are a big part of
the reason that we have success and so I
appreciate that I thought I knew that
you know I said this this morning on the
radio you know when we made this pick
and I'm trying to talk Microsoft teams
and tell those guys and I said hey guys
you know we're gonna pick jaylen Hertz
and hold on you know hold on to the side
of the boat because it's gonna get rocky
in the water and algae I guess and I
knew at first it would be like that but
I thought when our fans would go back
and watch highlights of this guy play
and go back and listen to him talk and
see how successful he was in college and
what kind of playmaker he is and and
what kind of person he adds to your
culture and teammate he is I thought it
you it would it would be kind of like
there would be excitement you know
because this is one of the best players
in college football over the last four
years and so I'm a little surprised but
I also understand it's only because they
want to win right now and I have a
different job you know my job is I'm
responsible for a lot of people you know
our coaches work hundred hour weeks our
staff works all the time in that
building and and I have to protect them
too you know so my job is kind of I got
one hand here who has to do everything
possible make sure Carson Wentz is
standing on that pedestal holding
Lombardi Trophy and I take that part
very seriously but I also got to do
whatever I can here to make sure that if
there's a couple
that he's missing especially as we go
with this new format you know we've seen
it we went forward to when Donovan
McNabb was hurt in 2002 kept home-field
advantage
you saw the Chiefs go to one this year
if they don't go to and one one Patrick
my home is out they're not they don't
have home-field advantage and so we've
had other experiences with that and
obviously we've had a couple experiences
the last few years and so you know I've
kind of think about and we kind of
talked about with all right if we pick
this position but what what if something
happens here cuz we got a good team you
know are we protected and that's a hard
job but that's my responsibility and I
have that obligation and it should be
easy on one hand to get the fan base to
understand that because the Super Bowl
championship from a couple of years ago
was the result of having a backup
quarterback in place who could step in
when carson wentz got injured i think
what made it harder for the local fans
to appreciate what you were doing with
Hertz was the fact that on Thursday
night
the Packers draft Jordan Love and we
spend all day with this narrative of the
Packers moving on from Aaron Rodgers why
else would they have taken Jordan love
and I think that was kind of hanging in
the air and it just kind of settled on
you because you had a lot of people with
that same knee-jerk reaction what the
hell they just paid carson wentz are
they trying to supplant carson wentz
with jaylen hurts do you think that
influenced that the fact that we were
still kind of reeling I had never
thought about it that way maybe because
I was just in the in the vacuum you know
like I was just kind of going around
around but listen I I could look you I
could look in my could look anyone in
the eye hopefully face to face at some
point soon and tell you we love Carson
Wentz and we've shown it with our
actions we showed it when we traded
everything to go and get him we showed
it when we went and paid him on that
contract and it's not like we're trying
to get out of that contract like we're
committed to that well we're trying to
build a football team that has
incredible deaths that we have this
value of this backup quarterback
position you know Jeffrey said like we
want to have two of the top ten
quarterbacks in the league like that's
our goal that's what we're trying to do
and we want to continue to do that
because we've had so many experiences
like this and Mike you know I maybe I've
said this then you've heard it but and I
talked about 2002 and doing that 2004
you played in the championship
donovan mcnabb got knocked out we play
with the backup quarterback we come back
in 2005 we had a BAC quarterback who had
5 and 11 the next year Jeff Garcia has a
backup quarterback we won the division 1
2010 Mike Vick starters backup
quarterback won the division 2013 Nick
Foles came in as the backup quarterback
won the division and then you know our
last three years so when we look at what
makes a difference in the terms of
winning and losing and how valuable this
position is you know it seemed to us
when we went back and forth about the
logic of this and obviously the
evaluation of the player and what he
could add to our team that it made sense
you know and I'm gonna peel back a
curtain just a little bit on my business
as you can imagine and as you've
probably experienced the people who
cover the NFL are competitive at times
they're a little petty at times are a
little catty so there will be a reporter
who throws an idea out there and another
reporter tells me about it says how
stupid is this idea to try to cajole me
into calling the reporter out because
every patient of doing that but anyway I
say that because somebody mentioned the
coronavirus connection here and that if
and when there's a season there's this
ever-present possibility that a key
player comes down testing positive not
necessarily having symptoms but testing
positive for the corona virus and that
that's a reason to have Jalen Hertz
around and this other reporters like all
this is stupid it's like actually it
makes sense I mean there's this random
Spectre that is gonna hover over your
every locker room if there's regular
testing of players which there will have
to be Carson Wentz is positive you gotta
have a quarterback for what 2-3 weeks
who knows were you thinking about that
at all this this ambiguity of the corona
virus and how it can knock guys out just
without really any rhyme or reason you
know I'd be lying if I told you that was
the primary factor in it but it makes a
lot of sense when I heard it you know it
kind of added another scent part of this
but you know the way I think about it is
for us to win a world championship right
now at a minimum we're playing 20 games
minimum we'll find twenty twenty games
right this 16 plus three I'm sorry
nineteen and I think for now 29 21 right
and then when it goes to 17 that's 20
that's a lot of games you better build
depth and we saw I mean we played in a
Super Bowl with our
Sartain left tackle without our starting
quarterback without a starting middle
linebacker without our third down
returner
without our best special team or just to
name a few you know last year we're
playing in the first round of playoffs
with without our right guard who we
thinks the best right guard in football
right tackle who he thinks one of the
best offensive line oftens tackles in
football certainly the best fried tackle
and football and then you know Carson
and the second series takes that
unfortunate hit which you know still
fires me up when they think about it but
I ship and flag should have been fine
right you can say it they know anyway so
so we get in a situation there we're
like we have to still keep our
priorities intact and there's no
question you know there were players
that were looking at there were good
players at that point as well but that
was the decision we made and I really
feel like you know the combination
because you know like we drafted a
safety in the fourth round and there
were a couple good safeties on the board
and so the combination of that of the of
Jalen + k tomas like we'll stand by that
those are good fires that were happy dad
to our culture to our football team so
do we see Jalen hurts on the field clear
this up for me because there's this idea
that he's gonna be like at a some Hill
we'll see him in different capacities
two quarterbacks on the field at the
same time even as he's serving as an
understudy to Carson Wentz will we see
that you know that's that's a better
question for Coach Petersen you know I'm
not trying to dunk it but I'm also you
know don't feel like that's that's my
dojo do you envision that in your own
mind do you think I'd like to see this
guy out there and see what he can do in
a different capacity than quarterback
regardless of what the coach is gonna do
I love Carson Wentz man I love Carson
Wentz and I love going to hit the bed
and I put my head on the pillow and
knowing that we have a strong
quarterback room that that to me makes
me sleep better one of the questions
folks had was the decision to take Jail
and rigor from TCU the first round
receiver a lot of people who you know
make the mock drafts and think they know
everything about the draft are surprised
that Rieger was taking there you
explained on Thursday night that you
picked him specifically because
compliments Carson Wentz the skill sets
explain how you think jail and Rieger is
the best guy who was a
at the time to compliment your
quarterbacks overall skill set yeah and
again you know you got to find things
that really fit your team with the
talent that fits your team and jaylen is
an incredibly talented guy and what he
does really well is he's got an
explosive skill set he could separate
vertically on the outside he could play
outside and inside but for us a guy like
that you can get the ball quick you too
on screens on jet sweeps who can return
who is has a vertical skill set you know
that fits our quarterbacks skill pattern
and really like I used this example of
going back watching the first game of
the year and when Dashon played in that
game and having him streaking down the
sideline and then her slot receiver
streaking down the sideline like you saw
the separation there but was also was
obvious to me was you had Zach Ertz in
the middle of the field screaming for
the ball wide open because safeties have
to play differently when you're able to
get that vertical threat when you're
able to have that speed on the field
and listen all you got to do is watch
the Chiefs play in the Super Bowl and
you see that you know you see obviously
when you do that so we have intermediate
threats you know that are unbelievable
we're really we loved our tight ends and
we drive to JJ last year we have al Sean
we've Greg Ward we have guys like that
it helps the running game it helps the
o-line helped supporter back and at the
same time like we think this is
incredibly talented guy and we started a
draft process last May and our scouts
are our front office does a great job
again and ahead of the next year draft
and saying here here are the strengths I
remember watching the receivers in Jalen
was coming off as 19 year old sophomore
with an incredible soft you know
credible year and just watching him and
going man this guy man he's lightning in
a bottle
last one before I let you go outside to
get your tower buzz by the Blue Angels
again draft great do you pay and I want
you to tell me the truth and I know you
always do do you pay attention to the
draft grades that are handing it out
after the process sense hell yeah I love
reading it on Monday I love reading
about it and then I'm this way I do I
put it in a lower right here and I close
it and I remind myself four years later
nobody knows anything today after the
draft man where people are chosen the
scheme's they're chosen the culture
they're chosen in - it all affects their
ability to be successful and so for
anyone for us for anyone to sit there
and say they know what's gonna happen
there's no way in that amazing though
that with all the work you put in all
the effort all the time all the study
it's still ultimately as a crapshoot as
to whether or not a guy is gonna make it
at the next level that you don't know
until he's out there competing against
NFL caliber talent and you think about
it I mean where else and what other
industry in the world are people coming
into that field for the first time and
judged in the first second third fourth
year on the job you know I know like I
hope I'm getting better every year I'm
learning more every year I'm trying to
pick the brains of more people every
year I'm getting more experience every
year so to think that like you know
people are being judged on what they do
at the outset of their career as 22 year
olds moving to new cities learning new
schemes maybe getting money in their
pocket for the first time and ultimately
people are gonna say in their career of
their choice there a bus based on that
initial glimpse at them it's ridiculous
and all you got to look at for our teams
Brandon Graham you know we drafted
Brandon Graham in 2010 and he wore this
label bust you know we why did we take
him over other players in that draft and
you know we have we got it we got a big
trophy in Philadelphia that was clinched
when he made the game saving play and an
amazing player amazing leader and it
just it takes time and it takes time for
everything in life but not a lot of
patience well on that note I'll let you
get outside take that trophy from the
Marlin out there and wave it around and
see if the Blue Angels remember it enjoy
the time with your family how he
congratulations on the draft thanks for
some of your time we'll talk to you soon
oh he's enjoyed talking with you man
stay safe we'll see
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports